how you doing creatures
of the internet i am dave rubin this is
the reuben report
direct message for today june 22nd
2021 as always share
this video subscribe to the channel
tap that notification bell that's all i
ask you
before we do anything else today
i want to address because it is june
22nd my favorite basketball player of
all time you know i mentioned charles
barkley yesterday
and i offered him a piece of locals you
guys saw that and we are reaching
through the proper channels to get to
barclay my agents were actually able
to get me his email address and his
phone number but i'm not
using him just yet we're going through
the proper channels for now
he is welcome to a piece of locals
because i want to free him but my
favorite basketball player of all time
actually played
with charles barkley the last two years
of his career was clyde drexler of the
portland trailblazers and then of the
houston rockets he was part of
phi slamma gemma university of houston
early 80s
it's his uh i guess he's probably like
56 now
it's his birthday today and i just want
to show you a 14 second clip tell me
this is not
the most underrated dunk in nba history
[Applause]
where's the hoop where's the hoop i mean
that has got to be the greatest dunk in
nba history i know people like that dr
jade
dunk you know jordan over the knicks
blah blah blah but anyway happy birthday
clyde
uh i'm uh you know i know we've we've
texted a little bit and just want to
wish you had a birthday
all right guys we've got a big show for
you today there's a lot going on first
off we're going to start with uh
some crime stats that have just dropped
out of some of the major cities yes the
progressively run
major cities and if you know i always
say the progressives aren't really good
at anything but they are good at
something
ruining cities and making crime and
murder explode
so we're going to dive into some numbers
on that and then the
two remaining stories for today are sort
of
offshoots of stuff we covered yesterday
and i like kind of linking things
together
because i think one of the problems that
we've got right now is every day it's
just like another crazy story another
crazy story
you you sort of think about one thing
and then they drop some other thing
and then you sort of forget like that
there's a narrative over time
that they're able to push on us so i
think linking stories to the day before
or the weeks before months before even
years before in this case
is quite good so yesterday i talked
about uh how chris ruffo who's the
lawyer
who's really been like in charge of the
fight against critical race theory in
our schools
and just doing a bang-up job going state
to state getting
this racist indoctrination out of our
schools
uh how he's been sort of slammed by
msnbc by joy reid and there's been a
whole bunch of hit pieces on him
well washington post did a spectacularly
awful hit piece on this guy but you
don't mess with chris ruffo cause he
went freaking
on the attack and he got them to retract
like
six things and i think it's worth
talking about not because it's the
biggest
story in the world but we need to
highlight
and and put the spotlight on people that
fight back because that's how we will
defeat this thing so he just demolished
the washington post it's just
spectacular and then the next story
talking about
a narrative over time we talked
yesterday about
don lemon over on cnn who was saying how
america basically hates
black people but they specifically hate
black gay people even though don
lemon is a black gay man who makes uh
four million dollars
a year at cnn lives in a very fancy
four plus million dollar mansion out on
long island blah blah blah again i don't
begrudge anyone doing whatever they want
with their own money
but back in 2014 don lemon sat down with
morgan freeman and his tune
on racism was very different why would
things have
changed we will discuss and that's all
we got for you today i think you're
going to enjoy it
but before i do anything else guys i
want
to show you my giant meat okay
i mean this is a serious i want to that
is a serious piece
of beef right there that i am going to
be cooking we got a ton
of visitors coming for the next week or
so uh because it is my 45th birthday on
june 26th
so i'm gonna be making some serious
prime rib uh guys i'm super excited
to be welcoming raise american as a new
sponsor to the reuben report
a company who raises the bar for premier
organic grass-fed
beef all over the country and yes they
sent me that and some
some filet mignons you know you think of
the filet mignon as just like a little
piece of beef like this but the filet
is actually a huge piece so we're going
to be eating well raised american has
been honing its processes to provide
lovers of beef the ultimate eating
experience from the feed to the cattle
to the state
raise american raises the standard of
what american organic beef ought to be
raise american cattle come from humanely
treated animals rigored on small
independent
american farms farms run by family
farmers and ranchers adhering to some of
the strictest animal welfare
and sustainable farming protocols
healthy cattle make healthy beef and no
one knows that better than the team at
raise american
raise american focuses on sustainability
which is why
they work closely with these family
farms to raise grass-fed organic cattle
which spend most of their lives grazing
pastures
in the fresh open air grazing in a way
that regenerates the soil instead of
depleting it
raise american is 100 organic 100
grass-fed
100 american go to raiseamerican.com
right now to order and learn more
good for you good for the planet good
for america and now back to me and by
the way guys you don't even need a code
with them because they're only
advertising
with us i chatted with the owners of the
company and the people who run the
operation they're they're just fantastic
we're going to be sharing some videos of
me grilling over the next
couple weeks you know i love being out
there at the grill so you don't even
need a code or anything because they're
just advertising with us
and you'd be helping out the show and
you'd be eating some delicious look at
the marbling
that's marbling people marbling all
right
i know people like it when i hold the
big piece of meat
let's talk about crime in major cities
because this has been a through line
really of the last
two years that pretty much if a
progressive is in charge of a city
murder crime and general mayhem
just absolutely spike so first off we've
got a chart here
this is from fox news it's actually just
incredible i know i've showed you some
versions of this type of thing
over the last couple weeks but this one
is just so stark
atlanta homicides up 58
shootings up 40 percent new york city
homicides only up 13
which is somewhat shocking that although
that may say more about the general
amount of homicides in new york uh
shooting's up 64
that's pretty impressive portland mama
mia portland portland by the way where
clyde drexler played and then left
portland he was a wise man he left
portland went to houston
so he left blue portland went to red
texas
but portland their homicides are up 533
shootings up a cool 126 percent chicago
homicides are up five percent
come back to me for a second on this one
because chicago we talk about this all
the time
every week in chicago about 40 people
are shot usually about five to 10 people
are killed you never see that on
mainstream media so the fact that their
homicides only went up five percent
that doesn't sound like a lot but their
baseline where they're starting it's
sort of like the new york city thing
although new york city is
i'll give credit where it's due new york
city is not nearly as bad but chicago is
starting so high on the homicide thing
they only notched up five percent uh and
shootings up 18
they usually have a ton of those los
angeles homicides up 22
shootings up 51 percent philadelphia 37
homicides and up 27
in shootings so look i know you guys get
it but this is the type of information
no one is disputing
those numbers so when you talk to your
friends because this is one of the main
things
that people talk to me about actually we
uh we did a meet up we did a locals
meetup in miami and one of the things
that people say to me
when they meet me is you know i love the
show blah blah blah but they always say
dave thanks for keeping me sane
thanks for keeping me sane that seems to
be a recurring thing
and one of the reasons that people don't
feel sane is because we're filled with
so much nonsensical news well
if you're in a conversation with
somebody and you want to show them
actual information clip this little
video or go to the source
go to the source go to fox where they've
got the actual numbers again nobody's
disputing this there's no progressives
as far as i know that are even disputing
these numbers
that i'm reading to you right now and
then say well wait a minute
if progressives are better about crime
or if defunding the police
makes sense or any of those things then
what or what is it that you can say
about these numbers i mean the videos
i'm
just seeing crazy videos every day of
the absolute mayhem
in these cities and if you don't if you
don't believe any of the numbers well
then
just check out this video we're going to
show you this is from fox news
the portland police riot squad is
all resigning literally
everybody is resigning because of the
mess that ridiculous progressive ted
wheeler the mayor in portland
uh has created in his city and these
guys know they don't have the backing
they know that there are antifa and blm
mobs just burning things down
attacking federal courthouses beating up
people on the streets stopping people
from
being on the roads and going over
bridges and a whole bunch more so the
entire police riot squad
is resigning right now take a look
well he's referring to the portland
oregon police riot squad officially
known as the
rapid response team and guess what all
of the team
all 50 of the officers they quit from
the prestigious team last week
they said they did that to protest the
indictment of one of their fellow team
members on an assault charge
for allegedly striking a photographer
while he was trying to break up a riot
on the streets last year city leaders
have denounced the mass resignations of
the officers
but the portland police association says
that decorated officer who was charged
was caught between an agenda-driven city
leaders and a politicized criminal
justice system
we had 150 plus days of
unprecedented sustained violence in the
city of portland
and our rapid response team along with
others from the police bureau
came out every night stood the line with
like you said molotov cocktails urine
feces rocks bottles everything else
thrown at them plus being docks their
home addresses being put out over
loudspeakers
their families being threatened be of
assaults
we had a murder during one of the riots
we have multiple assaults during the
riots
and also multiple assaults of police
officers during those same
riots the same district attorney who
indicted our officer declined 80 percent
of the crimes committed
during those riots by people 80 of the
people who were charged who were
arrested
by portland police during those riots 80
of those were declined
by the da's office i mean tell me you
don't have sympathy with that guy right
there some of the stuff he said is quite
extraordinary so basically every night
these guys were out there they know that
they don't have the backing of the d.a
or of the mayor ted wheeler the mayor by
the way who was
playing along with this right he was
talking about defunding the police and
everything else but you may remember we
covered it a few months back
when an antifa mob showed up at his
apartment complex
you know what he did he moved instead of
doing anything else he literally moved
he apologized to the people who live in
his apartment complex
and he moved okay so we've watched
portland just absolutely collapse again
over
what was it over 500 percent 533 percent
increase in homicide but listen to what
that officer said right there they those
guys go out there every night they're
not looking to hurt anybody
they're looking to maintain law and
order they're trying to keep
the peace they're trying to make sure
that a bunch of masked domestic
terrorists
don't ruin the lives of innocent people
they have feces thrown at them and urine
thrown at them molotov cocktails thrown
at them
they have uh they're being doxed where
they get on these
megaphones and they start screaming
their addresses out loud
this this is the type of thing that a
civil society cannot tolerate
at any level and it happens only in
progressive cities you know when i was
in miami a couple days ago and we're
going to release the interview with
mayor francis suarez in a couple days
when i talked to him about what it's
like
to have a thriving city and he talked
about backing up the police and making
sure people don't do illegal things and
taking care of the homeless problem
and progressives do none of those things
and everywhere
they go the cities get destroyed so i
have
absolutely nothing but sympathy and
empathy and compassion actually
for those officers and they did the
right thing it's like if you're not
being backed
by your d.a by your mayor
governor et cetera they're not fodder to
just
have feces and urine thrown on them and
to have their families
threatened also the extraordinary piece
that he said there was that the d.a
indicted the police officer who they're
talking about in this in this report
but he declined to prosecute 80 percent
of the antifa people who were arrested
do you understand that and by the way
this is the same thing where
kamala harris and ilhan omar and a bunch
of hollywood celebrities
have offered over the years to bail out
antifa people as they're arrested for
breaking
the law so you know if you're a democrat
and a progressive and a lefty you're
allowed to break the law burn down the
cities
and everything else but wisely these
police are not taking it
anymore and uh i feel bad for the
general the average person
in portland i actually have a friend in
portland uh who's lived in portland his
whole life i have a couple friends in
portland but i have one friend who's
lived in portland whole life
never wanted to leave loved the culture
of portland and the craft beers and the
key portland weird and portlandia and
all of that stuff
and it fit his job was kind of funky it
all fit and he just left
like at some point you push people long
enough and if you want
your homeless and and drug addicted
and crime-ridden cities then then you're
going to have them and
all the good people who are productive
and law-abiding they're
they're all going to leave
it really is as simple as that it's as
simple as that
all right uh i want to talk about
something that we covered yesterday
as you guys know chris ruffo lawyer had
him on the show a couple times
just one of the best this is a guy who
is so clearly
fighting critical race theory as i said
the other day there's a new meme out
there that no one can define critical
race they're either conservative critics
or critical race there we can't define
critical race theory i've had rufo on to
define critical race there i've had
james lindsey on just last week
to define critical race theory i don't
need to get into all
of the jargon about critical race theory
but in essence if you want to teach
white children that they are born guilty
because of the color of their skin and
if you want to teach
people that the founding of america is
fundamentally racist
and that things as i keep saying like
being on time and working hard
and knowing that two plus two equals
four and having believing in empirical
evidence if you wanna
uh believe that those things are
actually
good things then you're a white
supremacist this is according to
critical race theory okay
uh so anyway chris ruffo is really
making headway because he's going from
state to state
and he's talking to the legislators he's
talking to the governors and some of the
mayors
and they're getting critical race theory
out of the schools meaning it won't be
taught there he's not banning the ideas
so everyone keeps saying it's an assault
on the first amendment no it's not
no it's and no one's saying that you
buffoons can't talk about critical race
theory all you want on msnbc and then
people like me can mock you
but that doesn't mean we should be
teaching it the same way i wouldn't be
for teaching say
nazism in school right you wouldn't want
to teach nazism but you can teach about
the nazis that would be something well
anyway whatever
whenever someone comes out there and
starts making a difference in the world
we know this
immediately you're going to get the hit
pieces the new york times is going to do
it
remember a front page article about how
dave rubin leads people to the alt-right
through youtube yeah scary guy dave
rubin
we know about this all the hit pieces on
jordan peterson and ben shapiro anytime
anyone has anything interesting to say
that isn't sort of a brain dead leftist
progressive you're going to get massive
hit pieces
so the washington post ruffo knew it was
coming the washington post went all in
and tried to destroy him so here is a
tweet
about the piece from author and
journalist
her name is laura meckler she says a
look at the important role
chris ruffo has played in sparking and
advancing the gop
fight against so-called critical race
theory and how he
in his words turned research into
a salient political issue with a clear
villain now we'll show you the headline
of the article itself
and it's got a picture of chris ruffo
even in there and it's
uh the headline is republicans spurred
by
an unlikely figure see political promise
in targeting critical race theory okay
so so far it doesn't sound terrible now
they say
so-called critical race theory whenever
they want to besmirch something it's so
called right
well anyway i don't even need to read
the ridiculous article to you or quote
any of it because there were so many
errors in it
that rufo did the wise thing which is go
on the attack so this is just absolutely
beautiful this is a tweet
that ruffo sent out and an image about
the piece itself
and he wrote winning the washington post
hit piece against me has collapsed
they have admitted to fabricating a
timeline retracted or added
six full paragraphs reversed a key claim
and failed to produce evidence on
falsified quotation democracy dies
when the media lies and then there's an
image there
the post admits that they fabricated the
timeline of a timeline of events
surrounding my involvement
in president trump's executive order
issuing a correction
at the bottom of the story the post was
forced to retract
two paragraphs and add four paragraphs
to the story
reversing their reporting on a key
cupertino diversity seminar
which they had falsely claimed did not
occur this reversal vindicates my
reporting
post editor mike semel admitted to me
via email that the newspaper does not
have a recording or transcript of a key
quotation
that they falsified they claim the
reporter has
notes but cannot provide evidence to
support their original claim
post editor mike semele in an email that
virtually
all uh in an email that virtually all
white people contribute to racism
does not mean all white people are
racist this is an absurd position that
only an ideologue
could believe okay so you don't i get it
there's a lot of information there
the point of this is not uh to whittle
down every mistake that they made in
every retraction literally taking out
two paragraphs putting four more
paragraphs
retracting a quote that they completely
made up and everything else the point
is fight back people not only fight back
but know just because you read something
in the washington post
does not mean it's true as a matter of
fact it's probably the reverse
if you read something in the washington
post it's probably a lie
if you read something in the new york
times it's probably a lie and i'll go
even further
it's not just something it's
specifically when they attack
a person right because they do this all
the time
i was on tour with jordan peterson
we were in europe when there was a front
page
piece written in the new york times that
jordan peterson was for enforced
monogamy and it was a very very scary
piece
and it was also when hands may tell was
out and it was in the implication the
way it was written was very much like
jordan peterson wants to force women
to get married and then they'll
basically be sex slaves to pump out
units um and no that's not what he meant
what he meant was he liked the idea of
forced monogamy which in essence
is marriage meaning that marriage and
then the family unit is the basic
building block
of a functioning society which we all
kind of know
is true the author of that piece by the
way nellie bowles
is a former lefty who is now going
through a really interesting
political conversion i don't know if she
considers herself a conservative now i
think she still works
at the new york times but she's written
several pieces now
basically saying that she made a lot of
mistakes while she worked at the new
york times and i think she's still there
which is a little bizarre
but anyway the point is whenever they
write one of these things about a
specific
person just someone who's not woke who's
doing something good
you can basically say that that thing is
a lie
and again this all gets down to if you
have friends that are reading these
things
it's on you like if your little part of
saving the world
is waking your friends up to these
things and and going you know you know
next time you're at your house
you're at your friend's house let's say
on the weekend and you see they've got a
new york times
on the table there or they've got a
washington post on the table and they're
having coffee and it's like oh so you're
into the washington post
could you believe that that retraction
that they had to do on that guy chris
ruffo that was pretty nuts and they'll
go well what are you talking about
and they go well you're not going to
believe it and then you can actually you
can send them a clip
of this video or you can explain it
yourself or whatever it might be that's
how
we can fight back you know what i mean
we don't need to burn down everything
like they want to but i think that would
be
an effective way to do it so anyway
that's why i wanted to link
that right there rufo going on the
attack against one of the institutions
which by the way
it's not fun because they also can
coordinate all sorts of twitter bots and
trolls to attack you i've been through
all sorts of this stuff and they can
blow up reddit feeds and they can try to
attack book reviews and
they can make your life hell right they
can dox you i've been docs and have my
phone number leaked
and i've had people freaking sign me up
for porn sites that they then pay for
legitimately because my email got leaked
once
like crazy stuff but the point is i'm
still here i'm still fighting
ruffo's fighting and there's plenty of
other people fighting and we need you to
fight too
okay uh that brings me to the third
story about don lemon because don lemon
is the cnn anchor who thinks that
america hates
black people and america doesn't hate
black people and we fought a civil war
to end slavery we had a black president
most countries in europe that are way
older than us never had black prime
ministers
and we've done things over the years to
heal the legacy of racism and that is
not to say
that things are perfect but that dream
that that mlk guy wanted about
uh the arc of justice bending towards
more equality it's kind of here and that
we don't have laws that discriminate
although the leftists are actually
instituting some of those laws
but anyway lemon is an interesting
character because he is race-baiting in
the worst possible way while telling you
that america hates black people and
hates gay black people specifically
he a gay black man is making around 4
million bucks at cnn to go on every
night and pontificate
and get the rest of you ginned up about
racism
now again this gets to this thing about
how much time should we focus on msnbc
and cnn and washington new york times
because they're all sort of failing at
some level
but i do think it's important to call
these people out and and
expose them for what they are but in
this video i'm going to let i'm going to
let lemon expose himself so in 2014 this
is only seven years ago
he had a really interesting sit down
with morgan freeman and i want you to
listen to this
not only don but really listen to what
morgan freeman is saying
about race and then the second clip will
really reference
this thing that's happened in the last
couple days so take a look but it's hard
to
when you say that to some people because
they say oh there you go with it pull
yourself up by the bootstraps
thing and you know you're just being
respectable not everybody can do that
everybody can
everybody doesn't courage
courage is the key to life itself
there are a lot of people who are born
in situations and survive just
i'll never get out of this so they won't
i say to people who say well i i would
like to have done so and so and so
somebody could have done it
so well i couldn't get out of here man
the bus runs every day
you're exactly right yeah [ __ ]
everybody can yeah that's right morgan
freeman and by the way don lemon is sort
of acting as
the devil's advocate in the question
he's not even saying that he agrees that
people can't lift themselves up by the
bootstrap and by the end
he's agreeing with morgan freeman right
like that's that's pretty powerful stuff
but now
let's listen to what don lemon was
saying to his colleagues
about racism on cnn back in 2014
i thought what you said was fascinating
because you called it bull when you said
people can't you know
pull themselves up do you think that
race plays a part in
wealth distribution or either a mindset
that you can't truly
not yeah no you don't no i don't i know
you and i we're proof why would race
have anything to do with it
stick you put your mind to what you want
to do and go for that
uh it's kind of like
religion to me it's a good excuse for
not getting there yeah
you know i said it's probably get me in
trouble but i said
to some of my colleagues recently saying
so i know that it's an issue
but i've been it seems like every single
day on television i'm talking about race
and it's because of the new cycle it's
in the news but
sometimes i get so tired of talking
about it i want to i want to just go
this is over can we move on and if you
talk about it it exists
right it's not like it exists and we'd
refuse to talk about it
but making it a bigger issue
than it needs to be is the problem we
have
man morgan freeman that's it right there
making it the bigger
issue endlessly talking about it and
lemon is saying
seven years ago i'm sick of talking
about this
and in the previous clip morgan standing
were proof
that you as a black man can do anything
in america
right so you're actually lemon you're
delegitimizing your own existence as a
black man as a gay man whatever it is
like it's actually insane the the quote
there lemon sometimes i get so tired of
talking about it
i want to just go this is over can we
move on
so in two let me understand this in 2014
don lemon is saying that racism is over
can we just move on and seven years
later he's saying
america doesn't like black men
or particularly gay black men and that
is complete
nonsense you don lemon and your silly
little friends at cnn are keeping racism
on life support which is exactly what
morgan freeman is saying there
you can always talk about it and if you
always talk about it you will always
keep it going and now
because of that scary critical race
theory thing that you think none of us
can
define even though we define it all the
time you guys are the ones that are
making america more racist
there please somebody show me
someone on the right i don't mean some
loser twitter troll with a green frog
avatar i'm talking about show me someone
mainstream on the right a senator
a congressman someone who is
racist and is trying to put racism into
the system and wants there to be
different laws
for black people or doesn't want black
people to succeed
let's not forget congressional black
caucus sitting there like this as donald
trump during the state of the union
said that we had all-time low black
unemployment and i thought that would be
something they were for
but they decided they were less for that
rather than mostly they were just
against
orange man so you know look we can all
change right
i've changed we can all evolve we can
all get new information
and and look at the world in a different
way but the way
that don lemon is evolving is not
evolution
it's devolution right he's devolving in
his
in the in the thinking right racism is
over i want to tell my friends
and my colleagues you know we shouldn't
talk about this anymore let's move on
and now it's we got to talk about it
endlessly all the time
it's never enough and if i'm not
mistaken he just wrote a book about it
too
like lori lori people anyway
um i don't think any of this stuff is
going away but
as i keep saying to you guys i do think
more and more people are waking up
more and more videos of the moms
fighting back at the
at the school meetings and more and more
people are coming out and saying i'm not
gonna
do this and i'm gonna keep building
businesses that's what i'm doing with
locals
i'm gonna keep hiring you know we don't
i think i mentioned this the other day
at locals we are hiring right now if you
live in miami go to locals.com
jobs we're hiring and uh i hate to tell
you uh we don't care about your skin
color
and we don't care about your gender or
your sexuality what we do care about is
um your skills if you're skilled do you
know how to work and are you
hard-working and are you a decent human
being
and you want to build great stuff if you
are any of those things if you have some
combination of those things
we'd love to hire you or at least we'll
talk to you ja locals.com
jobs uh and by the way guys michael
knowles has a new book out
it has words in it you know his last
book which was
i believe it was called reasons to vote
for democrats it had no words in it and
it was a bestseller
this time he actually put words in his
book it's called
speechless it's out right now part one
of my interview with knowles who really
has become
i think one of the best political
pundits i know people don't like being
called a political pundit
but you know the best talkers that we've
got related to politics and the culture
wars
uh michael and i come at things from
very different perspectives but i find
that we
we agree on the big stuff and uh
the book is excellent i read it i gave
him a little shout out
in the book uh it's called speechless
it's out now so part one
is up on the youtube the full episode is
up already we go for about an hour
ad free at rubyreport.locals.com
that's it i got a couple meetings today
good things happening hope you have a
great day everybody
and whatever you do don't watch don
lemon on cnn tonight
but maybe watch a morgan freeman movie
doesn't that make you want to watch
shawshank
like that's shawshank right there that's
him talking to andy dufresne andy
you can do anything with your life and
don't worry sure you were
you know unjustly put here in shawshank
but you can go ahead and do anything
it's the same story
it's the same story and what did andy
know andy know that yes
was he in jail he was in jail but he
figured out a way
to beat the system that's what human
ingenuity is all about how was that for
a freaking
trip down something there uh have a
great day everybody i'll see you
tomorrow